[Music]  Selena Gomez is looking happy and  healthy following her reported treatment  for depression and anxiety here's the  wolf singer all smiles as she stepped  out to grab sushi with a friend in LA on  Thursday they'll rock trendy tiny Sony's  a navy wrap dress and white sneakers for  the outing it's nice to see Selena out  and about after completing a two-week  program in upstate New York for her  mental health fifty percent of my  recovery will be mentality and that's  something that I'm a huge advocate for  obviously I'm very vocal about working  on that part of you I think it's  important a source tells ET quote Selena  knows her health and wellness require  ongoing maintenance this most recent  stint was preventative she hasn't  relapsed and she's not in a bad place  quite the opposite our source adds she's  not afraid or ashamed to take a step  back and ask for help like she was in  the past I like to choose to live my  life in a way where I want to be wait  free  [Music]